y la salud mental es un concepto que se
compone de tres factores específicos la
salud física la salud psicológica y la
salud social estos tres factores
necesitan estar en armonía para que el
sujeto o el individuo logre
alcanzar un bienestar psicológico un
bienestar en lo que es el aspecto de las
aumentar en el campo de la salud mental
cuando hablamos de habilidades
emocionales hablamos de una capacidad
una habilidad que se puede desarrollar
que se puede entrenar es esa ese momento
donde vemos que alguien está molesto que
alguien está triste que alguien está con
miedo
la persona debe comprender la
importancia de identificar estas
emociones y encauzar esta energía de
forma correcta ya que no todas las
conductas son favorables cuando estamos
muy alegres no todas las conductas son
favorables cuando estamos tristes cuando
tenemos miedo entonces tenemos que
lograr cuando estamos sintiendo una de
estas emociones sobre todo emociones
como la ira en algunas ocasiones
detenernos
pensar varias posibilidades o vías de
acción y luego decidir esa vida de
acción que sería la más adecuada quizás
es un conflicto con una pareja quizás al
momento de responder a un jefe quizás al
momento de conversar con un hijo
entonces las habilidades emocionales nos
van a permitir a través de la
identificación de los sentimientos de
las emociones nos van a permitir
relacionarnos correctamente en una
sociedad y relacionarnos con nosotros
mismos también
bolivia presenta diferentes índices en
el ámbito de suicidio en el ámbito de
feminicidio en el ámbito del maltrato
familiar que son bastante
esclarecedores de que tenemos una
situación que hay que corregir
bolivia es el país con más suicidios en
adolescentes de toda latinoamérica
bolivia es el país el tercer país en
todo el mundo con más suicidio en
adolescentes también mostramos o tenemos
también presentamos índices de
feminicidios más alto que todos los
vecinos latinoamericanos países aunque
tienen índices de criminalidad más altos
bolivia aún así tiene índices de
feminicidios más altos entonces estamos
frente a una situación que no solamente
provocada por los confinamientos y por
el cob y aunque lo han aumentado y lo
han acrecentado también estamos en una
situación cultural a una situación
social que no se ha trabajado que no se
se ha procurado un cambio en ella si
bien el feminicidio aspectos como el
feminicidio no están directamente
relacionado o exclusivamente
relacionados a la salud mental si
contamos con factores de género el
feminicidio en específico es la acción
quitarle la vida a una mujer por el
hecho de ser mujer entonces estamos
hablando de una idea de un pensamiento
que es el que mueve esta acción un
pensamiento que donde se trabaja en la
salud mental en los ámbitos que van a
prevenir y van a ayudar a mejorar la
salud mental de la población y de la
sociedad en general no en santa cruz o
en bolivia hay una situación que hay que
lograr cambiar muchos trastornos
mentales muchas personas con diferentes
afecciones mentales pasan por actos se
le ponen diferentes etiquetas pero no se
trabajan no se no se curan o si ustedes
vienen en ellos y vemos a veces los
resultados esto no quiere decir que
exonere a la persona que comete un
feminicidio de cometer lo estamos
diciendo que estamos encontrando x
factores que podríamos identificar y
mediante esta identificación podríamos
estar previniendo entonces a través de
los trabajos sociales a través de
diferentes entidades prevenir que en
estas familias pueda llegar a ver estas
familias que tienen un factor de riesgo
de diferentes factores de riesgo puede
a sucede situaciones tan lamentables
como el feminicidio o personas que
podríamos identificar a través de los
servicios de salud primario y de otras
entidades que tienen factores de riesgo
para cometer un suicidio entonces la
salud mental
está ligada a cualquier campo del ser
humano está ligada a cualquier aspecto
donde esté el ser humano tenemos una
sociedad que le falta educación tenemos
una sociedad que le falta
saber o conocer dónde y cómo y la
importancia de resolver sus problemas
mentales de sus problemas emocionales de
resolver un tema de conflicto familiar
de saber qué y de desaprender y volver a
reaprender nuevas conductas que venimos
haciendo a nivel cultural a la crianza
de nuestros hijos en nuestras relaciones
de pareja y que en realidad no son sanas
tenemos que comprender que hay conductas
que aunque sean vengan de nuestros
abuelos o vengan de generaciones
anteriores que reaprender las para poder
preservar la salud tenemos entonces que
generar la necesidad de que la población
también requiera y busque este sistema
de salud mental
sería
creo de vital importancia que tanto a
nivel gubernamental en el sistema de
salud público como a nivel privado se
comience también a destinar esta está
este valor que tiene la salud mental y
que puede tener un profesional de la
salud mental dentro de un ámbito
hospitalario entonces no estaríamos
hablando solamente de unas
responsabilidades del ámbito público que
lo necesitamos también desde el ámbito
privado ya que nos encontramos en santa
cruz de la sierra en bolivia un seguro
de salud que realmente se dedique a
cubrir completamente la salud mental de
las personas sin embargo encontramos
algunos que están comenzando a buscar
opciones y a iniciar en este campo pero
nos falta mucho nos falta mucho por
trabajar y aún seguir ampliando la
atención en el campo de la salud mental
entonces nos encontramos en una
situación en bolivia donde hay un factor
fundamental la educación la población
no presenta o no muestra la necesidad de
la asistencia a los servicios de salud
mental las metas no a la salud mental
oficial a un psicólogo o psiquiatra ya
que existen en la sociedad diferentes
tabúes sociales que van a enjuiciar a la
persona que busca estas actividades
existe en la sociedad también la
costumbre de que las situaciones
emocionales podemos cubrirlas
con simples consejos en la casa cuando
la salud mental es algo tan complejo del
cerebro es algo tan complejo que
necesita la misma atención que le
daríamos a cualquier enfermedad médica
porque esa enfermedad física de otra
envergadura tocó una enfermedad física
donde el mercado era mayor no pedimos
cómo curarla en la casa vamos al médico
vamos al doctor y buscamos el
tratamiento lo mismo tenemos que lograr
promover en la salud mental las
cuarentenas impuestas por el joven 19
para la protección de la salud a causa
del coach 19
fueron un stop inesperado y único en la
historia de las generaciones que
actualmente vivimos un stop a nuestra
vida a nuestro diario vivir a nuestras
situaciones de pulsamos cada día a las
planificaciones a nuestras
programaciones ya desde desde ese
momento ya comenzó a ser un golpe no un
golpe
contundente
para nuestro esquema y nuestra
organización comenzamos a ver y
comenzamos a escuchar como las personas
cada vez generaban más ataques de
ansiedad generaban más situaciones de
desesperanza debido a situaciones al
mismo tiempo no solamente la cuarentena
en sí sino lo que conllevaba una pérdida
posible del trabajo el no poder salir a
trabajar un gran porcentaje de la
población boliviana es un trabajador
informal quiere decir que necesita salir
a la calle a hacer su comida del día sin
embargo nos encontramos a una situación
en la cual se tuvo que detener y no
tenía otra posibilidad entonces las
afectaciones que generó la cuarentena
podemos verlas ahora podemos verla en la
disminución que hay del contacto social
de contactos físicos podemos verla en el
aumento de casos con ansiedad podemos
ver las el aumento de estrés en el
aumento de suicidios en el aumento de
diferentes factores que están
relacionado directamente a la salud
mental maltrato familiar las personas de
pronto se vieron encerradas en pocos
metros cuadrados posiblemente en muchas
ocasiones con muchos conflictos que
pasaban por alto y podrían tapar y
podrían desviar y sin embargo acá se
vieron con la necesidad de enfrentarlos
bolivia por tanto tiene una necesidad de
promover su salud mental de promover no
solamente a nivel individual sino a
nivel social la educación en el ámbito
de la salud mental podemos comenzar con
actividad física que no obligatoriamente
significa de apuntarnos gimnasio es
comenzar a movernos más sobre todo ahora
que estamos en una situación donde el
trabajo y otros factores nos hacen estar
sentados tantas horas del día no podemos
mejorar nuestra alimentación la
alimentación que es tan importante para
todo el organismo
podemos comentar
nuestras relaciones sociales nuestras
relaciones afectivas relaciones que van
a favorecer en gran medida el correcto
desempeño del sujeto y la comprensión
que logra de sí mismo porque
somos seres que se socializan a través
del lenguaje y a través del lenguaje
mismo es que logramos comprendernos a
nosotros de ahí la importancia podemos
trabajar técnicas como el mindfulness
que nos van a ayudar a
relajar o despejar ese río todo nublado
en movimiento que tenemos a veces
nuestro pensamiento de room in acciones
nuestras ideas fijas y nos van a
permitir enfocarnos en diferentes
factores que nos van a ayudar a ver lo
que realmente no estamos viendo es
importante también y por último para
concluir acá algo imprescindible es
nuestras horas de sueño y nuestra
calidad de sueño tan importante como las
horas el sueño es para el ser humano
imprescindible es imprescindible porque
genera diferentes procesos en el
organismo
que van a ayudarnos a preservar nuestra
salud mental de los mismos crecemos
mientras los mismos reorganizamos
nuestros pensamientos mientras los
mismos nos curamos sin embargo vivimos
en una sociedad que actualmente por el
ritmo de trabajo que por el ritmo de
vida cada vez dormimos menos nos
acostamos tarde nos levantamos temprano
y creemos que mientras más estemos
despiertos más estamos viviendo sin
embargo
cada vez que estamos afectando a nuestro
sueño la calidad de nuestros sueños
estamos afectando también nuestra salud
entonces para terminar es importante una
correcta alimentación una calidad y una
cantidad de horas adecuadas de sueño
unas relaciones sociales y afectivas
adecuadas y de calidad el ejercicio
físico importante
serían aspectos que podrían ayudarnos
sin necesidad de ir a un consultorio y
preservar nuestra salud mental pero
importante siempre para tratar nuestro
tema de salud mental necesitamos y con
un profesional
[Música]